bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat examen de passage
réussi hier soir au sénat pour le projet
de loi de lutte contre le terrorisme
présenté par manuel valls le ministre de
l'intérieur ce texte doit permettre de
poursuivre les français qui commettent
des actes de terrorisme à l'étranger ou
qui y partent pour s'y entraîner au
jihad
il faut dire que le projet de loi a reçu
le soutien ici des sénateurs ump mais
aussi les sénateurs centristes au
premier rang desquels michel mercier
l'ancien garde des sceaux qui a expliqué
en séance qu'il voterait ce texte sans
deux états d'âme
l'ancien garde des sceaux qui a jugé que
le texte qui était soumis hier à
l'approbation des sénateurs reprenait en
partie à les propositions de nicolas
sarkozy formulés après l affaire mohamed
merah tout de suite donc direction l
hémicycle pour revoir l'adoption de ce
texte bonne séance à tous à l'article
additionnel après l'article 1er
amendement 18 rectifier il est présenté
par madame kikkoman home à damas et si
je pense qu'il a déjà été défendue dans
mon intervention sur l'article donc
voilà très bien il est défendu monsieur
le rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission sur le président cet
amendement tend à supprimer la
possibilité d'effectuer les contrôles
d'identité dans les trains
transfrontaliers
ce qui est une mesure qui avait été
instaurée par l'article 3 de la loi du
23 janvier 2006 s'il est vrai que ces
contrôles sont instaurés selon l'article
78-2 du code de procédure pénale pour la
prévention et la recherche des
infractions liées à la criminalité
transfrontalière et non pour la seule
lutte contre le terrorisme dans les
faits il permet aux services de
recueillir des informations qui leur
sont nécessaires dans le cadre de cette
lutte est là aussi
les auditions auxquelles nous avons pu
procéder démontrent que ces contrôles
ont leur utilité qu il est donc
souhaitable de les maintenir et c'est
pour cela que la commission
dans un avis défavorable à cet
amendement
ainsi monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre la vie du gouvernement même
avis favorable sur cet amendement y at
il des demandes d'explications de vote
il n'y en a pas que ceux qui souhaitent
adopter veut bien levé la main merci que
ceux qui sont contre veut bien levé la
main l'amendement n'est pas adopté
article additionnel après l'article 1er
l'amendement numéro 20 rectifier il est
présenté par madame benbassa en fait et
il vient compléter mon précédent
amendement
nous demandons qu'il y ait un rapport
qui soit fait avant la prochaine
provocation
et cela trois mois avant la prorogation
qui serait le 3 le 31 décembre
donc nous demandons pour le mois de
septembre une un rapport voilà c'est ils
complètent ce que ce que j'ai de ce que
nous avons demandé dans l'amendement
numéro un
merci merci cher collègue monsieur
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission le président c'est un avis
défavorable
cet amendement prévoit qu'un rapport
d'évaluation sur l'efficacité des trois
articles dont s'agit de la loi du 23
janvier 2006 devrait être rendue au plus
tard le 30 septembre 2014
nous considérons qu'un nouveau rapport
ne s'impose pas en l'espèce le
gouvernement et cela a été d'ailleurs
rappelé par le ministre s'il le souhaite
une prolongation supplémentaire mais ce
qui ne semble pas être le cas nous avons
bien entendu les propos de monsieur le
ministre devrait dans ce cas là à
justifier sa demande comme il l'a fait
dans le cas présent par le biais de
l'étude d'impact
qui a établi un bilan de l'application
de ces mesures mais nous avons eu une
réponse tout à fait clair tout à fait
nette de monsieur mise de l'intérieur
disant qu'elle était l'objectif et le
but qui sera poursuivie et qui sera
atteint par le gouvernement c'est
d'avoir un système unifié et donc on ne
voit pas aujourd'hui encore plus quel
serait l'intérêt de réaliser un rapport
alors que nous venons d'avoir cette
réponse parfaitement claires et précises
de monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur l'apporteur monsieur
ministre même avis négatif à vie y at-il
de demandes d'explications de vote qu'il
n'y en a pas que ceux qui souhaitent
adopter cet amendement va bien levé la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre veut
bien levé la main l'amendement n'est pas
adopté nous arrivons à l'article 2 je
passe la parole à madame christiane
taubira garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice monsieur le président la
commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames les
sénatrices mais messieurs les sénateurs
joe merci de me permettre de dire
quelques mots je vais souhaiter vous
rejoindre avant l'intervention de
monsieur le rapporteur cet après midi
j'ai quitté tardivon l'assemblée
nationale et je n'ai pu vous rejoindre
que juste au moment où monsieur le
rapporteur monter à la tribune
j'ai donc me contenter de quelques mots
puisque nous arrivons au seul article
contenant des dispositions pénales dans
ce texte de loi d'abord évidemment pour
confirmer ce qu'a dit le ministre de
l'intérieur à savoir les conditions dans
lesquelles nous avons préparé ce texte
le travail consciencieux et sérieux que
nous avons effectués mais que surtout
nos équipes ont effectué les experts que
nous nous sommes attachés respectivement
en fait nous avons tous bien entendu en
mémoire et vous l'avez dit à plusieurs
reprises ici les événements le drame la
tragédie d'il ya quelques mois avec la
firme ra le meurtre d'enfants de
personnes deux militaires et nous avons
tous vécu cette émotion la colère aussi
les peurs qui ne sont pas toutes
infondées
ces derniers jours nous avons eu des
raisons également de nous inquiéter
c'est donc avec la conscience d'une part
de la menace de la nécessité d'en
prendre toute la mesure et toutes les
formes d'expression mais aussi
d'anticiper
et d'autre part un souci d'efficacité
que nous avons travaillé parti à man à
ses dispositions concernant le code
pénal
nous avons donc souhaité répondre à la
question de savoir comment améliorer les
dispositifs dont nous disposons déjà à
savoir des dispositifs de repérage par
le renseignement des dispositifs de
prévention par les enquêtes
préliminaires et les informations
judiciaires et les dispositifs de
répression
la question n'est pas anodine parce que
il est apparu de des experts que nous
nous sommes attachés pour ses réflexions
il est apparu que parfois des précisions
sur des incriminations pouvait
fragiliser les possibilités dead
d'initiative des magistrats nous avons
donc voulu répondre à la façon de
construire un nouvel outil législatif
mais de de sorte qu'ils améliorent la
procédure aussi bien administratives que
judiciaire mais tout en nous posant la
question de savoir ce qu'ils pouvaient
relever du législatif ce qui devrait
éventuellement enlever du réglementaire
ce qui pourrait ressortir d'une
meilleure coordination entre les
services et éventuellement entre
l'administration et pourquoi pas sous
forme de l'instruction de politique
pénale
c'est donc sur la base de ces
interrogations très précises que nous
avons confronté les situations nous
sommes attachés je le disais des
personnes des praticiens donc des
magistrats du siège juge d'instruction
du pôle antiterroriste
les magistrats du parquet de la section
centrale de la lutte antiterroriste des
policiers partir mans espère et
spécialisés et des juristes notamment de
la cour de cassation parce que nous
disposons également d'une juridiction
d'une jurisprudence pardon qui donne une
interprétation notamment de
l'incrimination d'accession
d'association de malfaiteurs avec des
visites héros terroristes et cette
jurisprudence et d'une interprétation
large qui permet aux magistrats de
travailler de sorte que nous avons été
alertés sur la nécessité de ne pas
prendre le risque
par des incriminations complémentaires
plus précise de fragiliser de permettre
que ces incriminations d'association de
malfaiteurs lorsqu'elle est mobilisée
soit fasse l'objet d'une exigence de
précision par les magistrats
cette disposition donc de l'article 2
qui permet donc d'introduire un article
113 13 dans le code pénal est une
modification importante puisque elle
change le livre 1er du code pénal en
élargissant la compétence territoriale
de nos juridictions françaises cette
rédaction qui est sensiblement
différente du texte précédent porté par
le garde des sceaux michel mercier s'est
rédaction et plus large dans la mesure
où au delà de l'association de
malfaiteurs
elle permet également d'inclure des
personnes qui sont liées au terrorisme
par nature et sous une autre forme
notamment avec des revenus ou des moyens
qui ne pourraient pas être justifiée ou
simplement des personnes convaincues de
financer les actes terroristes
c'est donc un élargissement du champ
d'application de cette disposition qui
permet également de 2,2 d'incriminer des
français qui agirait à l'étranger même
si ces pays eux ne crimine pas c'est les
actes perpétrés
évidemment il y à ce travail fait sur le
code pénal il ya l'essentiel des autres
dispositions du texte qui concerne la
sécurité intérieure ainsi que le code
sur l'entrée et le séjour des étrangers
et du droit d'asile
mais il y a bien entendu vous l'avez
évoqué quelques uns d'entre vous dans
vos interventions cet après midi il ya
bien entendu l'action publique du
gouvernement qui est plus large et en ce
qui me concerne pour répondre à quelques
sénateurs sur la radicalisation qui peut
être opéré dans les zones aux
établissements pénitentiaires c'est une
réalité dont il faut prendre la mesure
sansan la surestimer parce que la
surestimer reviendrait à sous-estimer ce
qui peut se passer dans certaines
parties du territoire sans que ces
personnes aient eu un parcours
judiciaire et pénitentiaire donc en tout
cas il y à 20 % à peu près des personnes
incriminées par les derniers par
l'attentât de sarcelles et par le réseau
que nos nos policiers et nos magistrats
en détecter et combattent actuellement
il y a à peu près 20% des personnes
incriminées qui ont eu un parcours
judiciaire et pénitentiaire
donc ça veut dire que nous ne devons pas
perdre de vue qu'il ya d'autres lieux de
radicalisation par ce qui se passe dans
nos établissements pénitentiaires nous
avons deux difficultés actuelles
auxquelles nous essayons d'apporter des
réponses
une des difficultés c'est effectivement
que dans nos établissements mais je
crois que le garde des sceaux l'avais
déjà repéré et des mesures avaient déjà
été prises
nous les avons conforté dans nos
établissements il y à des imams
autoproclamés ou en tout cas des
prêcheurs autoproclamés qui prêchent un
islam radical qui peut être haineux et
ses prêcheurs autoproclamé sont
identifiés sont repérés identifier et
lorsque le prosélytisme est établi ils
font l'objet d'un transfèrement
les surveillants pénitentiaires eux
suivent une formation notamment à
l'école nationale de la magistrature qui
leur permet de disposer d éléments qui
qui aident à détecter ces pratiques et à
prendre la mesure du risque réel il
existe également vous le savez je crois
probablement que tout les sénatrices et
sénateurs le savent bureau de
renseignements pénitentiaire qui
travaille avec les services de
renseignement de la police et qui nous
permettent donc de contenir ce phénomène
de radicalisation dans un établissement
pénitentiaire
ceci étant nous constatons en ayant
étudié le profil des personnes qui se
trouvent impliqués dans ces processus
dick alisation à l'inter de nos
établissements il apparaît que sont des
personnes qui sont d'une vulnérabilité
pour la plupart d'entre elles bien
entendu et ça ce n'est pas un élément
d'atténuation c'est un élément factuel
ce sont des personnes qui sont dans un
état de vulnérabilité économique qui
sont souvent prises en charge de façon
matérielle à l'inter des établissements
et qui le sont parfois même assez
souvent à l'extérieur il y a donc à
répondre aussi à la réalité de
l'indigence dans certains de nos
établissements et faire en sorte que
cette vulnérabilité économique se
réduisent ensuite pour répondre aux
besoins de culte à la demande de culte
lorsque elles existent elles existent
dans nos établissements nous disposions
pour l'instant d'une capacité parce
qu'il ya un grand déséquilibre sur la
répartition des vacations pour la
pratique des cultes un grand
déséquilibre très très défavorable au
culte à la confession musulmane nous
avons donc décidé pour l'année 2013 de
créer un certain nombre de vacations
supplémentaires qui nous permettront de
couvrir une trentaine d'établissements
supplémentaires en 2014 nous couvrirons
à nouveau une trentaine d'établissements
supplémentaires dont progressivement
nous rééquilibrant nous créer les
conditions nous créant les conditions de
la pratique du culte puisqu'elle est
légal dans notre société laïque dante
république laïque qui n'est pas une
république de contestation de la
pratique du culte mais une
république avec un principe de
coexistence aussi bien de l'athéisme de
l'agnosticisme de la libre conscient de
la libre pensée que de toutes les
confessions nous créons les conditions
pour la pratique de cette confession
dans le respect de la loi des lois
républicaines et du des principes
républicains
voilà donc en termes de politiques
publiques ce que nous faisons en plus de
ces dispositions pénales qui sont
contenus contenues dans ce texte
au titre de l'article 2 merci madame la
garde des sceaux nous en arrivons à
l'eau nous en arrivons à l'amendement 10
rectifié bis il est présenté par
monsieur mercier
monsieur le président je voudrais
simplement présenté cet amendement le
plus rapidement possible dans le projet
et qui devait présenter le gouvernement
propose de pouvoir poursuivre un
français à nationale qui à l'étranger se
livrent à des actes de passion ou de
terrorisme je propose qu'on aille un peu
plus loin et que l'on prévoit également
que on puisse poursuivre les gens de
personnes résidant habituellement en
france et pour essayer de bien fixer une
catégorie et ne pas être trop large dans
la définition de la commission des lois
ce matin a beaucoup travaillé j'ai
accepté sans problème de modifier
l'amendement est de parler de personnes
titulaires d'un titre de séjour
n'autorise en à résider sur le
territoire français je crois que ça
répond que l'on recherchait et que cela
nous permettra nous permettra à tous les
cas de parfaire l'arsenal juridique dont
disposeront des policiers et magistrats
merci cher collègue monsieur rapporteur
quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur le président madame monsieur le
ministre
l'amendement tel qu'il vient d'être
présentée par monsieur le ministre
mercier recueille un avis favorable de
la commission peut dire ce matin ça a
été un peu une oeuvre collective sur la
base de la proposition de monsieur
mercier
l'article 2 qui est la novation en
principal de ce texte qui ne crée pas
une nouvelle incrimination mais qui est
une extension d'incrimination permet de
poursuivre les crimes et délits qualifié
d' actes de terrorisme commis par un
français hors du territoire la
république monsieur mercier proposé de
considérer qu' il fallait l'étendre à
ceux qui avaient leur résidence
habituelle en france la commission a
trouvé que le mot résidence habituelle
risquait de poser des problèmes que ce
n'était pas suffisamment précis et donc
nous sommes arrivés à un texte où cette
incrimination viserait des crimes et
délits qualifié d' actes de terrorisme
commis par une personne par un français
ou par une personne titulaire d'un titre
de séjour l'autorisant à résider sur le
territoire français c'est effectivement
une définition qui recueillait peut le
dire l'accord de toute la commission et
c'est donc un avis tout à fait favorable
le rapporteur sur ministre l'avis du
gouvernement ce président il est
difficile pour le gouvernement de se
poser à une oeuvre collective du sénat
et de la commission des lois
vous savez ça a été dit la loi pénale
déjà applicable à ressortissants
étrangers qu'a commis un crime ou un
délit puni d'emprisonnement hors du
territoire de la république
il n'y a donc pas d'obstacle à
l'élargissement des dispositions de
l'article 113 13 du code pénal au
ressortissant étranger résidant
habituellement en français la commission
sur le ministre monsieur le rapporteur a
très utilement préciser cette notion de
résidence habituel
en la remplaçant par l'exigence de la
détention d'un titre de séjour
et puis serait au fond cohérent que les
résidents habituels en france soient
passibles des mêmes sanctions pénales
que les français pour les mêmes faits
commis à l'étranger pour toutes ces
raisons le gouvernement est favorable à
l'amendement de monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le ministre je n'ai pas
de demandes d'explications de vote si
monsieur lamy oui merci monsieur le
président madame la garde des sceaux
monsieur le ministre
chers collègues bien que ne faisant
partie ne faisant pas partie de la
commission des lois parce que le mérite
revient à la commission des lois et je
comprends parfaitement
cet amendement présenté toujours avec
beaucoup de brio dans le garde des
sceaux michel mercier
et c'est vrai que je dirais bon avec un
regard peut-être plus plus neutre parce
que michel merci à rappeler tout le
travail qui a été fait j'irai au sein de
delà de la commission présidée par notre
collègue monsieur sueur et aussi le
travail assidu du rapporteur je salue
aussi naturellement bas tout le travail
que les collègues ont ont fait sur sur
ce dossier et sur 7 sur ce texte sur cet
amendement en particulier et c'est vrai
que
tout à l'heure l'intervention de madame
le garde des sceaux sur cet amendement
ont fait état de la sécurité intérieure
la sécurité intérieure au sein au sens
large
naturellement les interventions au sens
de la de la justice naturellement puis
de l'autre côté la sécurité intérieure
sous toutes ses formes dont j'oublie pas
non plus puisque ça a été rappelée
sécurité intérieure bon de faire
référence et le président jean jacques
hyest à l'époque connais bien aussi ce
ce sujet c'était une loi qui a été votée
en 2011
je rends janvier 2011 sur la loi loppsi
2 bon c'était aussi une partie pendant
lequel il y avait aussi la nécessité
gérait de 2,2 de travailler aussi sur
toutes ses formes aussi donc
parallèlement ça s'ajoute naturellement
avec je dirais cet amendement qui ajoute
naturellement à la notion de 2 j 6 et
puis aussi les luttes de sous toutes les
formes
j'irai conte le terrorisme et je crois
que les témoignages des uns et des
autres qui sont intervenus vont aussi
dans ce sens là je remercie ses chers
collègues je n'ai pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement avait
bien levé la main merci je n'ai pas
d'opposition
il est adopté nous votons sur l'article
2 pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter va
bien levé la main merci opposition il
est adopté
article additionnel après l'article 2
nous avons deux amendements identiques
qui font l'objet d'une discussion
commune
l'amendement de rectifier bis et
présentée par monsieur est spacieux le
président parce que le président mr 2010
mercier est beaucoup plus compétents que
moi puisque il avait rédigé le projet de
loi alors il s'agit en fait simplement
de transposer la décision qu'a du 28
novembre 2008 relative à la lutte contre
le terrorisme qui exige de réprimer
comme acte de terrorisme chantage
en vue de commettre des actes
terroristes cambier ja existe déjà mais
en vain
fra préciser les choses je pense que
c'est indispensable de le mettre
si on veut respecter la décision cadre
de 2000 du 28 novembre 2008
merci chers collègues
monsieur mercier nous présente le 11
rectifier le président il s'agit d'être
allemand de d'ailleurs complètement
similaire celui qui vient de présenter
monsieur y est elle est la question que
nous voulons poser au gouvernement c'est
pourquoi refuser transposer la décision
cadre du 28 novembre 2008 alors qu'elle
est là et qu'il faudra à transposer et
pourquoi attendre un autre texte pour le
faire
je crois qu'il y a là l'occasion de
faire cette transposition et et
simplement de montrer aussi que la lutte
contre le terrorisme s'est pas
uniquement avec du droit national c'est
aussi avec l europe qu on peut le faire
on peut pas lutter coteaux terroriste
uniquement dans notre pays on sait bien
que les frontières ne font pas beaucoup
peur aux terroristes vous propose donc
de transposer et la décision cadre du 28
novembre 2008 avec ces deux amendements
en ajoutant de chantage dans la liste
des infractions constituant un acte de
terrorisme
il y aura second amendement qui
reprendra d'autres dispositions de cette
même directive
merci cher collègue monsieur rapporteur
quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur le président madame le garde
des sceaux monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
l'avis de la commission c'est une
demande de retrait ou sinon un avis
défavorable pourquoi l'objet de ces deux
amendements c'est de nous dire qu'il
s'agirait de transposer la décision
cadre du 28 novembre 2008 relative à la
lutte contre le terrorisme qui exige de
réprimer comme acte de terrorisme le
chantage en vue de commettre des actes
de terrorisme
cet amendement en fait
qui vise comme je lé d'y inclure le
chantage
nous considérons qu'il est déjà
satisfait par le droit en vigueur
puisque dans la liste des infractions
constituant des actes de terrorisme
figure l'extorsion qui dans notre code
pénal recouvre différents incrimination
parmi lesquels le chantage et j'ai sous
les yeux
monsieur le ministre mercier
effectivement le code pénal l'article
312 1 et nous sommes dans le chapitre 2
qui a pour titre de l'ex de l'extorsion
il ya deux sections la première section
première c'est de l'extorsion que la
section 2 12e section
c'est du chantage donc nous considérons
que cette précision que cette précision
n'est pas utile si monsieur le
rapporteur
monsieur le ministre quel est l'avis du
gouvernement manas avant adam a gardé
son nom j'ai presque envie de vous
laisser continuer mais évidemment c'est
pas manquer sur la police de la de
l'assemblée mais c'est simplement parce
que nous partageons le point de vue du
de la commission pour vous dire qu'en
parce que lors de la discussion sur la
la la décision-cadre de 2008 le
gouvernement de l'époque le gouvernement
de l'époque a considéré que le droit
français satisfaisait à cette
disposition et le les autorités
communautaires à aucun moment n'ont
considéré elle que ça n'était pas le cas
le chantage dans notre droit en fait
concerne les biens et non pas ce que
vous entendez ce que vous suggérez à
savoir l' acte qui consiste à
contraindre quelqu'un à agir
donc nous considérons que notre droit
satisfait à votre demande
parce que dans les extorsions j'ai lu
votre l'exposé des motifs
j'ai lu aussi
pardon pardon chimiques aussi aussi
l'étude d'impact l'étude d'impact de la
donc voilà c'est parce que dans les
extorsions le chantage et est prévu et
que par conséquent votre demande est
satisfaite par le droit en l'état actuel
dit madame la ministre
alors monsieur mercier pour explication
de vote au retrait
c'est d'abord pour ménager la voix de
monsieur y est personne ne conteste ici
que dans le code pénal au parent du
chantage et personne ne conteste que le
chantage soit une infraction pénale
mais je dois quand même vous dire qu'il
s'agit pas de ça c'est pas ça la
question
oui parce qu'on parle de terrorisme et
dans le code suez dans le code pénal
peut être que vous nous avez lu monsieur
le rapporteur
je veux bien maxi d autant que vous
voudrez et il ne le chantage dans le
code pénal ne constitue pas un acte de
terrorisme
la transcription que nous vous proposons
de la directive européenne
c'est de dire que le chantage sera
inscrit dans la liste des infractions
constituant un acte de terrorisme et est
le faire tomber dans le droit du
terrorisme c'est ce que dit la directive
européenne
c'est ce que nous disons et c'est tout à
fait vrai est ce que vous allez dire sur
rapporteur le chantage est une
infraction pénale
mais c'est pas un acte de terrorisme et
nous souhaitons qu'il soit reconnu comme
un acte de terrorisme
c'est ce que dit la directive cadre
européenne
et puisque nous sommes en matière pénale
il faut bien sûr interpréter la loi
pénale de façon stricte étroites ou
restrictives
c'est ce que rappelait portalis qui
veille sur d'autres travaux ce soir d'un
discours préliminaire sur le code civil
où est il ce pas la peine de ricaner
parce que dans beaucoup de chance de
l'avoir
et c'est quand même encore lui qui fait
l'essentiel de notre droit l'abri cette
génération regarde le bien
il cherche collègue madame madame la
ministre je les lui monsieur le ministre
effectivement en fait dans les actes de
terrorisme il ya les extorsions d'accord
et dans les extorsions
il y a le chantage voilà c'est juste
cela c'est très précis alors je vous lis
voit la page 2 non j'ai juste
j'ai juste un tempérament amazonien
pardonnez moi
non le dieu voulait les ouïes 421 je
vous demandais rien donc voilà les ia la
déclinaison des actes constitutifs de
l'incrimination de terrorisme parmi eux
il ya les extorsions et lorsqu'on se
reportent dans le code pénal
oa aux extorsions il y a le chantage
voilà donc merci aux 4 421 donc nous
avons constituent des actes de
terrorisme
deuxième alinéa les vols les extorsions
les destructions et lorsqu on repasse
donc elle page merci nous avons voilà
merci nous avons donc parmi les
extensions le chantage
ce n'est vraiment pas pour vous être
désagréable c'est juste que ce serait
superfétatoire par rapport aux aux
infractions définies dans notre code
pénal
si madame ministre la parole est à
monsieur jean jacques hyest
tiens moi le président on peut être
d'accord mais je pense quand même qu'il
faut mieux le préciser à ce que non
parce que on raisonne le garde des
sceaux je crois que je connais un peu
cette partie du code pénal vous voyez
bon il ya les extorsions globalement
puis extorsion et chantage
puis deux choses différentes ah oui et
on se prononce sur des à mon avis pas
sur des titres mais sur des infractions
et il ya le chantage qui est pas
l'extorsion moi je suis désolé c'est pas
les mêmes parties c'est tout antoine
qu'au mont voix voilà c'est pourquoi je
retire pas non plus mon amendement mais
a retiré un service alors sur ces
amendements pour explication de vote la
parole à monsieur richard
en ayant écouté avec intérêt cet échange
il me semble aux termes de l' échange
possible d'essayer de convaincre mes
collègues y est et mercier que du fait
du pluriel employés par l'article dans
le quartier l'article 421 qui parle d
extorsion de même que des destructions
cela veut dire qu'on fait allusion à une
série homogène l'incrimination sinon on
dirait l'extorsion et si on dit les
extorsions cela recouvre en effet les
deux sections que mentionnait le
rapporteur tout à l'heure c'était des
réflexions relatives à l'extorsion qui
est un délit qui à cette date sa
définition et au chantage donc il me
semble alors qu'en effet le début de la
discussion prête à hésitation que en
tout cas avec les travaux préparatoires
qui seront demain ou après demain dans
le journal officiel
on peu réputés que le dispositif actuel
du code pénal répond aux exigences de la
décision-cadre européenne merci chers
collègues je n'ai pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter ces amendements veut
bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veuille
bien levé la main des amendements ne
sont pas adoptées nous arrivons un
article additionnel après l'article de
l'amendement 7 rectifié vi il est
présenté par monsieur y est le set
rectifiez vi e doit me fatiguer puisque
il s'agit aussi de transposer une
disposition de la décision car du 28
novembre 2008
alors donc je rappelle que l'amendement
permet une mise en conformité de la
décision cadre en réprimant le recruteur
indépendamment de la réussite ou non du
recrutement
moi je pense que c'est indispensable
pour se mettre en harmonie avec la
décision maintenant on va peut-être le
prouver que ça y est déjà
si cher collègue monsieur le rapporteur
qu'est la vie la commission le président
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
je suis désolé pour notre collègue jean
jacques hyest mais c'est effectivement
un avis défavorable
l'amendement n'est pas une surprise
parce que vous connaissez bien monsieur
le l'ancien garde des sceaux la
législation et que vous êtes
certainement convaincu à de ce que je
vais vous indiquez puisque nous vous
l'avons dit ce matin cet amendement tend
à instituer une nouvelle incrimination
inspiré du délit d'association de
malfaiteurs mais appliqué à une personne
agissant de manière totalement isolé
l'association de malfaiteurs en lien
avec une entreprise terroriste a déjà
permis et nous le savons une prévention
efficace des actes de terrorisme
alors faut-il aller plus loin ce que il
faut le rappeler aucun des acteurs de la
lutte contre le terrorisme n'a demandé
dans les auditions préparatoire à
l'examen de ce projet de loi
parce que si l'association de
malfaiteurs qui est quand même la base
de notre système pénal de lutte contre
le terrorisme peut être constituée à ses
vieux assez facilement elle exige à
minima une entente ou la participation à
un groupement même si ce groupement
n'est formé que de deux personnes
jusque-là au monsieur
une telle exigence ne serait même plus
nécessaire dans le délit qui est proposé
ici puisque vous visez d'un acte
solitaire
une telle exigence donc ce n'est pas
recevable pour nous et en l'état cette
nouvelle infraction nous paraît vraiment
très insuffisamment encadrée merci
monsieur rapporteur madame la ministre
l'opinion du gouvernement oui le
gouvernement partage l'avis de la
commission du sénat a exprimé à
l'instant par le rapporteur
actuellement rien n'interdit concernant
une personne isolée de procéder à une
surveillance administrative et si ces
personnes comme vous l'indiquez dans
votre amendement détient des actes
matériels qui peuvent attester d'une
préparation une
une information judiciaire une procédure
judiciaire peut être ouverte
donc pour ces raisons nous pensons que
le droit couvre cette situation qui
concerne la préparation éventuelle de la
pièta choristes
merci madame le ministre
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
amendement avait bien levé la main merci
que ceux qui sont contre veut bien levé
la main l'amendement n'est pas adopté un
article additionnel après l'article de
deux amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune
l'amendement un rectifié bisky présentée
par monsieur y est sûre le président le
nouvel article 421 2 4 réprime
l'instigateur d'actes de terrorisme de
manière très similaire à ce que
prévoient les articles partie 221 5 1 2
du même code qui réprime l'incitation à
commettre un assassinat d'un tel cas en
effet la personne n'ayant pas été encore
recruter il n'y a pas il n'y aura
peut-être jamais d'association de
malfaiteurs ce délai permet ainsi de
réprimer de façon spécifique
l'instigation matière de terrorisme
comme l'exigent la décision cadre du 28
novembre 2008
merci chers collègues
l'amendement 12 rectifier et présentée
par monsieur mercier
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le président
comme cela a été dit fort bien dans par
madame le garde des sceaux que par
monsieur rapportant la législation
française permet d'ores et déjà en
application de l'infraction
d'association de malfaiteurs terroristes
d'appréhender tous les actes commis en
amont d'une infraction terroriste telle
que la participation la préparation
d'actes de terrorisme
l'effet de recrutement et d'entraînement
pour le terrorisme cependant la
législation actuelle ne couvre pas le
cas de l'individu qui cherche à recruter
d'autres personnes pour une association
de malfaiteurs à des fins terroristes
mais n'y parvient pas
elle est aujourd'hui le code pénal ne
peut pas permettre de cette poursuite
l'amendement proposé qui est d'ailleurs
l'intégration dans notre droit interne
de même directive dont nous avons parlé
tout à l'heure c'est donc cet amendement
permet une mise en conformité de la
décision cadre en réprimant le recruteur
indépendamment de la réussite ou non du
recrutement afpr qu'elle nous avons
déposé cet amendement
si cher collègue monsieur rapporteur
quel est l'avis de la commission sur le
président madame monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues s'agit d'un
effectivement de deux amendements
intéressant il cet amendement permet de
réprimer l'instigation en matière de
terrorisme
alors cette infraction peut être
poursuivi aujourd'hui sur la base du
délit d'association de malfaiteurs
terroristes mais il reste quoi il reste
le ministre il reste toutefois le cas de
l'instigation non suivies d'effet et on
peut considérer effectivement on peut se
poser en tout cas la question de savoir
si cela ne constitue pas un vide
juridique
alors il nous a semblé au niveau de la
commission avant de nous provenons c'est
qu'il était souhaitable de demander
l'avis du gouvernement sur par rapport à
cette interrogation
merci monsieur rapporteur la mamie dise
quel est l'avis du gouvernement monsieur
le président nous partageons l'analyse
de
de la commission et sans forcément
d'ailleurs monsieur le président y est
et monsieur le garde des sceaux de
monsieur le ministre
sansan nous référer nécessairement
d'ailleurs à la décision-cadre de 2008
du point de vue simplement de notre
droit l'interrogation est de savoir si
le droit actuel couvre bien cette
situation très particulière d'une
personne sur une autre personne une
personne seule c'est une autre personne
seule la décision-cadre d'ailleurs
concerne des groupes elle donc ça n'est
pas une transposition de la
décision-cadre qui répondrait à vos
interrogations
la question que nous nous posons c'est
de savoir si en introduisant cette
disposition nous ne faiblissons pas le
recours à l'association de malfaiteurs
et parce que nous n'avons pas eu d'avis
tranché sur cette question nous le
gouvernement souhaite s'en remettre à la
sagesse de l'assemblée
merci madame la ministre je n'ai pas de
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter ces amendements
veuille bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veut bien
levé la main merci abstentions ils sont
adoptés article additionnel après
l'article 2 2 amendements font l'objet
d'une discussion commune l'amendement 3
rectifié bis présentée par monsieur y
est oui monsieur le président là j'ai
dit que c'est un débat récurrent tout à
l'heure où est-ce qu'on sort de la loi
de sur la liberté de la presse
le fait de provoquer directement à des
actes terroristes l'apologie est-ce
qu'on doit la sortir de la loi sur la
liberté de la presse
ou est-ce qu'on doit dans le cadre de la
loi sur la liberté de la presse
trouver les moyens à la fois en matière
de prescription et en matière de
contraintes notamment en ce qui concerne
la détention provisoire voilà c'est un
vrai débat nous et pour je propose que
ça soit extraire de la loi de 81,1 et de
faire un délit spécifique mais je sais
qu'à d'autres amendement de repli aussi
qui permettront peut-être de trouver une
solution plus partagés merci chers
collègues
l'amendement 13 rectifiée présentée par
monsieur mercier merci beaucoup de ceux
présents très naturellement cet
amendement poursuit le même but que
celui qui vient de décrire le président
y est
il s'agit en fait de permettre une
poursuite réel des actes de foi de
jacques de provocation des actes de
terrorisme ou l'apologie de ces actes
actuellement c'est la loi de 1881 qui
permet de poursuivre et de punir de tels
actes je rappelle que la loi de 1881 est
une loi de liberté c'est la loi sur la
liberté de la presse et cette loi
elle permet une action dans des
conditions très restrictives
parce que c'est ça fait partie de nos
grandes lois fondamentales qui ont
permis de bâtir l'état libéral
républicain que nous connaissons
pour ma part je choisi une autre voie
que celle retenue par monsieur n'y est
peut-être pas monsieur le rapporteur
je préfère voir sortir en quelque sorte
de la loi de 1881 à la poursuite de
l'apologie des actes de terrorisme ou la
provocation à des actes de terrorisme
elle a fait rentrer dans le droit commun
avec quelques limitations que l'on verra
dans un amendement ultérieure si jamais
le sénat souhaitait adopter l'amendement
que je propose
voilà c'est le même but mais par une
voix différente et moi je pense très
honnêtement que toucher à la loi de 880
ce n'est peut-être pas la meilleure et
la plus sage des solutions c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vous en propose
une autre merci cher collègue monsieur
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission sur le président madame le
garde des sceaux monsieur louis chers
collègues dans les deux cas ce sont en
l'état des avis défavorables c'est un
problème de fond puisqu'il s'agit de
savoir si on sort malgré une méthode
j'ai le dire un peu habile de monsieur
le ministre mercier qui ne prend pas le
même chemin mais pour arriver au même
but mais on arrive au même au même
objectif
cet amendement monsieur y est tu en as
intégré dans le code pénal le délit de
provocation d' apologie d'actes de
terrorisme qui à l'heure actuelle figure
dans la loi du 29 juillet 1881 sur la
liberté de la presse
avec comme sanction sont des faits qui
sont passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement
en application de l'article 24 de la loi
de 1881 alors
il est vrai que le délit se voient
appliquer le régime particulier du droit
de la presse notamment
et c'est important en matière de
prescription c'est à dire une
prescription abrégée de 3 - si les
dispositions et c'est vrai de la loi de
1881 ne paraissent pas tout adapté à la
répression de cette infraction nous
paraît quand même préférable de rester
dans le cadre de cette loi
cette loi en effet présente des
garanties procédurales nécessaires à la
liberté d'expression c'est pour ça que
c'est un débat qui n'est pas neutre
c'est un vrai problème de principe et il
est possible aussi de l'aménager cette
loi de 1881
comme cela existe déjà pour certains des
délits qui sont aujourd'hui mentionné
par cette loi sur deux aspects nous
pourrions aménager cette loi sur le
délai de prescription qui pourrait être
allongée comme le prévoit l'amendement
numéro 4 vis de monsieur y est à un an
passerait de trois mois à un an et sur
éventuellement la possibilité d'un
placement en détention provisoire
et c'est l'objet du sous-amendement que
je proposerai à l'amendement numéro 4 au
10 mai la vraie question de principe
c'est de savoir si on reste dans le
cadre de la loi de 1881 il nous paraît
vraiment que en l'état il serait tout à
fait souhaitable de rester dans la
configuration de la loi de 1881
merci monsieur rapportera garde des
sceaux tel est l'avis du gouvernement
présidents le gouvernement partage
l'avis que vient d'exposer leurs
rapporteurs de la commission du sénat
parce que
nous avons dit tout à l'heure que
l'arsenal législatif pour lutter contre
le terrorisme est international de droit
mais qui déroge au droit commun il
déroge au droit commun simplement c'est
un dispositif qui respecte un équilibre
entre les nécessités les impératifs de
l'ordre public et le respect de nos
principes constitutionnels et de nos
engagements internationaux
mais il déroge au droit commun donc il
ya des dispositions particulières cette
loi de 1881 1 est une main sur la
liberté d'expression
lorsqu'on réprimer actes de terrorisme
il y à la répression de la l'expression
et à la répression de la préparation
la répression de l'action l'expression
n'est pas traitée dans notre droit de la
même façon que la préparation où
l'action
l'expression est traité d'une façon
générale je parle pas d'expressions de
l'apologie du terrorisme et est traitée
l'expression à traiter de façon générale
dans la loi de 1881
la loi de 1881 sens yonne l'apologie
sanctionne l'apologie dans les
dispositions qui sont prévues dans
l'article 280 le gouvernement n'est pas
favorable à ce que ces dispositions
traverse de cette loi de 1881 au code
pénal
j'ai pour ma part donné instruction aux
parquets généraux comme l'auriez oublié
fait je n'en doute pas
pour que les lames l'apologie de
terrorisme soit autant que possible
lié à l'association de malfaiteurs ça
permet d'abord déjà de suspendre le
délai de prescription
ensuite si au cours de l' enquête il
apparaît que l'association de
malfaiteurs n'est pas retenue le délai
de prescription ne s'est pas épuisé et
il est possible de sanctionner l'auteur
de cette apologie donc pour ces raisons
je vous rappelle d'ailleurs que le
l'article 52 de la loi de 1881 permet
permet la garde à vue c'est la dépasse
c'est une décision pardon c'est une
décision du
de la cour de cassation qui date de
février 2012 et qui donc que cette cet
article ne permet pas la détention
provisoire mais permet la garde à vue
donc voilà là le gouvernement tient à
faire la distinction entre l'expression
la préparation et l'action et considère
que dans la loi de 1881 1
sous réserve de la discussion que nous
aurons tout à leur relative à
l'amendement sur l'allongement du délai
de prescription
nous souhaitons maintenir cette
infraction dans la loi de 1881 consolidé
merci madame la garde des sceaux pour
explication de vote monsieur mercier
merci beaucoup je peux dire est en effet
deux voies qui peuvent être utilisés la
garde des sceaux sur un porteur vous
avez choisi de rester dans le cadre de
la loi de 1881 honnêtement je suis pas
très convaincu par ce que vous nous
dites moi je crois présentement il faut
conserver la loi de 1881 par ce que vous
dites on graisse dans ce cadre on va
quand même lui tordre le cou à la loi du
ca 80 un petit peu petit peu à macérer
on va allonger le délai de prescription
parce que vraiment c'est pas possible de
faire dans des lettres prescription de
droit commun de la loi de 1881 et puis
quand même on va prévoir la détention
provisoire parce que sinon ça marche pas
by c'est quand même un amendement de
sous-amendements de monsieur le
rapporteur et si vous ne voulez pas
prendre sous amendement du rapporteur
faut se dire maintenant porter on
regarde clairement les choses
sinon on n'y arrivera pas moi ce que je
regrette aussi c'est que si on reste
dans cette loi badham le garde des
sceaux
tout peut on peut justifier et c'est pas
c'est pas ça la question
mais on va perdre des points essentiels
de l'efficacité de l'action
antiterroriste qui est du point de vue
de la justice
la concentration de toutes les actions
anti terroriste au sein du tribunal de
grande instance de paris et du parquet
et de paris les litiges sur la presse il
peut y avoir autant de
tribunaux saisis qui n'existent de
tribunaux de grande instance et on va et
on va éparpillés l'action contre le
terrorisme et on va perdre en efficacité
ce que l'on avait avec l'action du
tribunal de paris et du paquet de paille
c'est aussi une des raisons qui fait
faire cette proposition mais après tout
si vous dites que vous n'avez pas besoin
c'est votre choix c'est vous qui êtes
responsabilité mais je crois vraiment
que c'est se priver d'un moyen d'action
importants pour lutter contre le
terrorisme
merci chers collègues à part la
terrifiante yann elies pour explication
de vote
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
moi je soutiens totalement la position
de madame la garde des sceaux pour une
raison simple c'est que depuis le début
de cet après-midi et sans doute même
auparavant
il ya un consensus sur l'idée que nous
ne devons pas accepter une législation
d'exception
nous ne devons pas et nous acceptons qui
est des dispositions exceptionnelles et
tous nos droits aujourd'hui sur le
terrorisme est fondé sur cette idée
regardez par exemple quel est le pivot
de la répression en matière de
terrorisme
c'est l'association de malfaiteurs revue
et corrigée spécialisés avec selon
l'association de malfaiteurs qui vise
les terroristes c'est du droit commun
adaptés justement autorise on ne crée
pas une nouvelle infraction l'on adapte
le droit commun parce qu'on ne se
méfient d'une législation d'exception
là on al houthi qui est là depuis des
siècles plus d'un siècle maintenant qui
la loi de 1881 sur la liberté de la
presse
cette loi a fait ses preuves c'est vrai
qu'elle a des contraintes de procédure
particulière mais c'est aussi au fond à
un accord moment précis cette loi permet
contrairement ce que vous venez dire
tout à l'heure elle permet de rézé déjà
une détention provisoire donc qui aura
pas inventé la détention provisoire
avait déjà prévu madame la garde des
sceaux nous a précisé tout à l'heure qui
avait un arrêt de la cour de cassation
qui permet également la garde à vue
c'est ce qu'a dit mais a gardé la garde
à vue mais la détention provisoire au
regard relisez la loi de 1881 vous
verrez qu'elle est également prévue dans
le texte
eh bien
nous avons cette loi là il suffit
également de l'adapter et donc nous
pouvons poursuivre les mêmes objectifs
que vous mais tout en restant dans le
cadre de la législation de droit commun
si chers collègues la parole à monsieur
bertrand pour explications de vote le
terrorisme il faut privilégier
l'efficacité moi je suis d'accord avec
la proposition de monsieur y est pour
que ça rejoignait les règles de droit
commun en matière pénale parce que bon
la liberté de la presse est bien entendu
que c'est quelque chose sacrée
l'excellent à protéger la couvre de nos
yeux mais en matière de terrorisme et
dans la période actuelle
je préférerais comme privilégie
l'efficacité
chers collègues d'apparaître à monsieur
le président de la commission mais c'est
sûr monsieur le président madame et
monsieur les ministres je pense que nous
sommes devant un sujet très difficile et
je considère pour ma part que nous
devons respecter la loi de 1881 sur la
presse
et s'agissant des publications rester
dans le sas faire car le sujet est
difficile j'ai eu l'occasion de dire en
commission qu'il existait par exemple
aujourd'hui dans toutes les librairies
un livre qui incontestablement fait
l'éloge d'une personne qui a je ne sais
pas si c'est du terrorisme enfin ça
relève du terrorisme qui a tué un grand
nombre de jeux de d'êtres humains il a
été condamné pour terrorisme et ce livre
existe il a donné lieu à une pétition de
nombreux auteurs de la maison gallimard
la question de savoir par rapport au
droit publié à écrire à imprimer ce
qu'il convient de faire est une vraie
question
je ne réponds pas de manière simple mais
c'est une vraie question
faut-il interdire emprisonné demander
des comptes à l'éditeur à l'auteur etc
voilà un sujet on ne peut pas le traiter
à la légère d'autant plus que si on
regarde l'ensemble de la littérature on
trouvera beaucoup de textes qui abordent
cette question alors on pourra dire ce
n'est pas l'auteur c'est le personnage
eu ça se discute
il y à des oeuvres odieuse exécrables
qui ont été imprimés et qui on est et
qui ont donné lieu à sanction
mais voyez vous il ya là matière à
jugement et il me paraît sage que ce
jugement reste dans la sphère du droit
de la presse je ne préjuge pas ce n'est
pas notre rôle mais reste dans la sphère
du droit de la presse
c'est pourquoi le avant tour je me
permet d'appuyer de soutenir la position
qui est à la fois celle de madame le
garde des sceaux et celle de notre
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président je n'ai pas
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter ces
amendements venir lever la main ah
pardon excusez moi madame la garde des
sceaux
je vous en prie quelques mots pour
informer en fait tout à l'heure je
disais que il y a nous nous sommes
interrogés manifestement nous continuons
à le faire c'est vraiment la valeur
ajoutée du débat parlementaire
nous nous sommes interrogés quant à
savoir si nous avions besoin de nouveaux
outils législatifs qui avaient des
dispositions qui relèverait plutôt de
décisions réglementaires et s'il y avait
sur le plan opérationnel
une meilleure articulation affaire il y
a en l'occurrence une meilleure
articulation à faire et j'ai donné des
consignes en ce sens entre le cercle de
la section antiterroriste et la section
presse du parquet de paris
parce que vous avez raison c'est le
problème que vous avez évoquées dans
votre dernière intervention monsieur le
ministre vous avez raison il ya là à
coordonner articuler les choses donc sur
sur le législatif nous faisons
avec la précautions nécessaires pour ne
pas fragiliser ce qu'on appelle la
colonne vertébrale de notre de nos
moyens législatifs contre le terrorisme
c'est l'association de malfaiteurs et
puis pour le reste nous regardons bien
là où nous pouvons agir et il y à une
meilleure coordination de services aussi
à faire au delà de ces deux sections du
parquet de paris gagnait en coordination
à faire ce qui est commencez déjà par
exemple entre eux
l'adea ségéla des séries la dgpn donc
voila nous nous avons aussi à rendre nos
services plus performants à la fois par
plus de moyens à la fois par d'autres
répartition des effectifs a à la fois
aussi par l'évaluation des méthodes avec
eux mêmes à partir de leur expertise
l'évaluation des méthodes mises en
oeuvre mais nous croyons aussi qu'il est
important dans l'histoire de 2,2
voilà du droit français de maintenir les
dispositions particulières de la loi de
1881 en apportant les aménagements
nécessaires liées à la situation à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés
merci à la garde des sceaux alors nous
votons sur l'amendement 13 rectifier que
ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter veuille
bien levé la main sur le 13 rectifier
que ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter
veuille bien levé la main merci que ceux
qui sont contre veut bien levé la main
il n'est pas adopté nous votons sur le 3
rectifié bis que ceux qui souhaitent
adopter veut bien levé la main merci que
ceux qui sont contre veut bien levé la
main il n'est pas adopté
article additionnel après l'article 2 2
amendements font l'objet d'une
discussion commune
le ciss rectifié qui est présentée par
monsieur y est
monsieur le président je l'évoqué
également la discussion générale je
crois que c'est un débat qui est
nécessaire c'est là que je propose la
création d'un nouveau délit de
consultation de sites internet
terroriste sera aucun motif légitime à
l'instar de ce qui est déjà prévu
prendra-t-il 20 227-23 en matière de
consultation habituelle de sites
pédopornographiques
seule sera sanctionné la consultation
habituelle de site provoquant actes de
terrorisme ou faisant l'apologie de
cézac lensoise et site comporte des
images montrant la commission d'actes de
terrorisme consistant des atteintes
volontaires à la vie voilà l'objet de
cette annonce
merci chers collègues le sous-amendement
numéro neuf tombes
monsieur le rapporteur quel est l'avis
de la commission sur le site rectifié
sur le président madame le garde des
sceaux monsieur luis mes chers collègues
c'est un avis défavorable dire et après
mûre réflexion et de la commission en
prenant cet avis défavorable
je crois entendu les arguments des uns
des autres c'est un vrai problème
une vraie question qui est posée par le
président y est je dois dire que moi
dans durant toutes les auditions que
j'ai pu faire
j'ai posées régulièrement la question
aux responsables de nos services d'
enquêtes aux magistrats sur la question
de savoir s'il était en l'état utile
efficace de prévoir
la mise en place la création d'un
nouveau délit de consultation habituelle
de sites incitant à commettre des actes
de terrorisme ou en faisant l'apologie
veut dire que globalement je retire de
ses auditions que ce n'était pas à
quelque chose qui était considéré comme
utile et efficace en l'état je ne dis
pas que c'est en fonction de l'évolution
des choses
la question ne se repose pas mais je
dois dire au sénat ce que j'ai ressenti
au cours de ses éditions
alors effectivement ça pose un certain
nombre de difficultés sur l'efficacité
de cette éventuelle nouvelle infraction
il faudrait d'ailleurs parce que on nous
dit à un exemple c'est ce qui existe sur
la consultation habituelle de sites
pédopornographiques qui est elle une
infraction qui existe je crois qu'il
serait utile d'avoir un retour
d'expérience sur les conditions de mise
en oeuvre du délit de consultation des
sites à caractère pédopornographique sur
les effets de cette incrimination il
semble pas en l'état qu'il y ait quand
même un bilan tout à fait positif en
tout cas démontrant une réelle
efficacité
il ya une deuxième interrogation que
nous pouvons soulever aussi et qui est
quelque chose d'important et nous
l'avons tous rappelés dans le débat dans
la discussion générale celle équilibre
entre l'impératif de sécurité qui est
tout à fait justifiée dans des questions
de terrorisme et tous ici nous l'avons
dit de manière très claire
et puis le respect de la liberté
individuelle que jusqu'ici notre arsenal
législatif en matière de lutte contre le
terrorisme
c'était forcé
de préserver et je crois que là nous en
l'état nous irions à mon avis trop loin
et que ça ne serait pas une bonne chose
merci monsieur rapporteur madame le
garde des sceaux
quel est l'avis du gouvernement le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur messieurs les sénateurs il y a
d'abord une observation c'est que cet
amendement n'apporte pas des moyens
nouveaux hauts magistrats
en fait pour intervenir d'une part et
d'autre part c'est une disposition qui
était dans la version que vous aviez
rédigé monsieur le ministre de ceux du
texte anti terroriste et cette
disposition avait été avait fait
l'observation du conseil l'objet
d'observations du conseil d'état et
voilà donc pour les mêmes raisons le
gouvernement considère qu'il vaut mieux
s'en passer merci à damas grâce aux
explications de vote monsieur béchu
merci monsieur le président madame la
garde des sceaux monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président monsieur rapporté
en mai chers collègues quand on décide
de créer une taxe
elle s'applique de manière immédiate à
tout le monde quand on décide de créer
un délit
on donne la possibilité aux juges de
pouvoir ensuite utiliser le cas échéant
et si nécessaire j'avoue que je ne
comprends pas la position de mes
collègues je peux entendre le débat
constructif serein et apaisé que nous
faisons d'avoir sur la loi de 1881 sur
la liberté de la presse et sur le fait
que si on touche à certains aspects de
notre édifice juridique on est
susceptible de remettre en cause des
équilibres mais dès lors qu'il s'agit
d'ajouter un délit de surcroît par
rapport à une consultation de sites
internet dont nous savons aujourd'hui
que c'est un des lieux où se joue une
part de l'apprentissage au terrorisme
j'ai apprécié madame la garde des sceaux
vos propos tout à l'heure sur le fait
dire que
le fait de renforcer à l'intérieur des
prisons certains moyens pour éviter des
dérives pour éviter que des gens qui
soient laissés à eux mêmes avec des
informations tronquées avec une
propagande religieuse qui ne ferait pas
l'objet d'une réflexion intelligente ou
soutenue était un moyen d'éviter ensuite
le passage à l'acte d'un certain nombre
de gens et on a sur internet aujourd'hui
un espace sur lequel malheureusement une
propagande sans filtre une propagande
qui peut se faire avec des moyens
visuels pour imiter des gestes
précisément peut prendre un espace peut
prendre peut amener ensuite à une
instrumentalisation à une propagande à
un embrigadement qui peut entraîner un
passage à l'acte et les arguments selon
lesquels ça ne paraît pas absolument
nécessaire ou selon lesquelles on
pourrait éventuellement les utiliser un
jour si le besoin s'en faisait sentir ne
me convainquent pas je préférerais qu'on
se met en situation de créer le délit
quitte à ce que les magistrats ne
l'utilisent pas sinon vois pas l'utilité
mais qu'on ne laisse pas une zone de non
droit par rapport à l'internet alors
qu'il est d'ores et déjà acquis que
c'est un espace aujourd'hui sur lequel
la propagande se met en place et je
pense très sincèrement qu'au temps il ya
eu des positions qui ont été défendues
ce soir pour essayer de préserver un
équilibre qu'on peut comprendre et qui
font l'objet
peut-être pas d'un accord à 75% à
l'image de la popularité ce soir de
notre ministre de l'intérieur mais en
tout cas d'un assez large consensus sur
ces bancs mais que en l'espèce sur cette
disposition précise le gouvernement
s'honorerait à accepter un ajout sur le
plan juridique qui sera à la disposition
des juges et les forces de l'ordre
le cas nécessaire lequel schéma c'est
chaque collègue madame classe pour
explication de vote
oui merci monsieur le président à
l'inversé ce qui vient d'être dit
justement quand on crée une taxe c'est
quelque chose de simple quand on
s'attaque à l'outil internet c'est
quelque chose de beaucoup plus compliqué
le fait de créer un délit vert pour la
consultation de certains sites internet
on le sait c'est inévitable et c'est
extrêmement rapide va créer la création
de techniques de contournement qui vont
faire que les forces de police vont
beaucoup moins bien remonter la piste
des personnes qui consultent justement
les sites internet terroristes et qu'au
contraire on va obérer et on va empêcher
l'activité des forces de sécurité via
ces voies de contournement
j'en avais déjà parlé à l'époque
justement des sites pédopornographiques
on n'imagine pas aujourd'hui la vitesse
à laquelle vont les technologies et les
contres technologie sur internet donc il
me semble à moi justement surtout
aujourd'hui où les services enquêteurs
nous disent n'y touchez pas ça ne nous
servira à rien d'en faire un délit au
contraire ça risque de nous empêcher de
monter nous enquête correctement c'est
eux qu'il faut écouter et non pas
l'impression que de créer un délit va
empêcher l'exécution d'action au
contraire on risque la favoriser si cher
collègue monsieur richard pour
explication de vote
je ne voterai pas l'amendement proposé
par nos collègues mais je suggérer au
gouvernement de poursuivre sa réflexion
sur le sujet parce que l'ensemble des
actes qui concourent à une entreprise
terroriste sont variés et il est clair
que l'utilisation de sites qui à la fois
encourage et conseil fait partie de ces
actes
donc nous n'avons pas ici puisque l'avis
du conseil d'état est la propriété du
gouvernement ne vont pas peut-être
l'ensemble des facteurs qui conduisent
le gouvernement à ne pas souhaité
l'instauration de cette de cette
incrimination supplémentaires mais
l'ensemble de le dispositif pénal de
lutte contre le terrorisme est fondée
sur la sanction d'actes qui ne sont pas
des passages à l'acte final et si je me
place d'un point de vue d'économie de
moyens là des séries n'a pas les moyens
humains de piste et tous les apprentis
terroristes est obligé de travailler un
peu par priorité est donc dans certains
cas le fait de pouvoir entamer une
poursuite contre une personne est
quelque chose qui sera un obstacle dans
la suite de son action donc moi je suis
convaincu que l'existence une fois
claude l'ensemble des conditions
juridiques en aurait été éclaircies
l'existence de cette incrimination
serait un outil de plus dans la palette
dont dispose la république pour lutter
contre la montée vers la passage à
l'acte alors je ne propose pas qu'on
improvise et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle je me garderai de rejoindre les
collègues qui lance le débat aujourd'hui
sur un amendement mais il me semble
vraiment que le gouvernement serait bien
inspiré de poursuivre sa réflexion sur
le sujet merci chers collègues je passe
la parole à monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président très
simplement il s'agit de la création d'un
délit de consultation hors jeu les
indiqué tout à l'heure les enquêteurs
les services spécialisés considère
aujourd'hui que ça ne leur apportera pas
en l'état un moyen efficace ça ne les
empêche pas le fait qu'il n'y ait pas de
délit
d'aller sur le net d'enquêté de faire un
travail
bonds est manifestement ça posera
d'énormes problèmes d'identification
ça pose aussi et je crois que la
réaction de monsieur le ministre mercier
a été très claire par rapport à ça il ya
eu un avis qui a été rendue sur sur le
précédent projet de loi nous irions
aujourd'hui vers des difficultés
je ne crois pas que ce soit justifié
véritablement est pour ça que j'insiste
vraiment pour que l'on aille pas
aujourd'hui en ce sens là si monsieur la
porter la parole est à madame la garde
des sceaux
oui juste pour rappeler qu'il s'agit de
la consultation
c'est un délit de consultation j'entends
la nécessité de réfléchir
nous l'avons dit nous l'avons et pour
nous ça n'était pas un aveu de faiblesse
de dieu que nous nous sommes beaucoup
interroger beaucoup
jusqu'où nous allons dans la précision
jusqu'où nous allions dans
l'élargissement jusqu'au nous allions
dans l'approfondissement de certaines
incrimination là dans le cas d'espèce
nous traitons de la création d'un délit
de consultation de sites si il ya une
suspicion des enquêtes administratives
peuvent une surveillance administrative
peut être enclenchée y compris sur une
personne isolée
oui voilà c'est ce que je dis mais là
nous sommes dans la consultation c'est à
dire que si dans la consultation
il ya des éléments qui permettent de
penser que ce n'est pas une simple
consultation et nous nous ne sommes pas
totalement désarmé il ya des choses qui
peuvent être enclenchée et qui vont qui
vend qui vont se poursuivre après la
question sera de savoir à quel moment on
va passer de la procédure administrative
à la procédure judiciaire parce que
c'est elle qui sera efficace
oui oui mais parfait parfait
chers collègues ses collègues oui bien
sûr monsieur le ministre avait justement
c'est bien pour ça que nous pensons que
juste le fait de consulter un site
chers collègues je ne m'aimais gg de
demandes d'explications de vote
monsieur y est pour explication de vote
je préfère les explications franchement
d'al-arich arc d'autres soit il faut
surtout pas le faire parce que ça
pourrait nuire aussi au fait qu'on
poursuive autre chose désolée
ou bien on considère ces dangereux comme
la pédo pornographie et ça peut mener à
autre chose et on peut créer le délit
ça n'empêche rien sur le renseignement
le renseignement cet autre jour le
renseignement il est justifié
on écoute on bien entendu mais s'il n'y
a pas de délit on pourra pas poursuivre
après est-ce qu'on est bon je vais
maintenir cet amendement pour le
principe
il sera pas voté et je pense que nous y
reviendrons parce que le débat n'est pas
terminé
merci monsieur ministre ne reviendrait
pas sur le président hu faisait
messieurs les sénateurs sur les
arguments qui ont été excellemment
développé par christiane taubira et par
le rapporteur
nous sommes devant un problème il a été
souligné les magistrats nous disent
qu'ils n'ont pas besoin de cette
incrimination
deuxièmement nous faisons face à un
problème à caractère constitutionnel et
nous n'avons pas voulu avec la garde des
sceaux sur un texte aussi important dans
un moment aussi délicat prendre ce
risque
mais bien évidemment et nous en sommes
d'accord il y assure la question
d'internet et surgelés longuement
développé tout à l'heure à l'occasion de
la présentation du texte
le développement de ce gie à 10 mhz qui
recoupe des modes très différents la
comparaison
moi j'étais assez intéressé par la
comparaison avec
tout ce qui se passe sur le net en
matière de pédopornographie et j'étais
sensible à cette comparaison mais il y a
une limite quant à l'extension et au
type au fond de discours de propagande
qui ne peut pas être totalement
apparenté à cet autre délit qui fait
l'objet d'un travail tout à fait
considérable d' alerte ou par les
policiers spécialisés par les magistrats
nés en revanche vous avez raison je lis
est monsieur richard nous faut
travailler sur ce sujet là ne sais pas
si nous y reviendrons tout de suite en
tout cas de toute façon le parlement et
de ce point de vue là souverain il faut
que nous trouvions entre le gouvernement
et le parlement et les techniciens pas
uniquement les spécialistes du droit
parce que nous le savons bien
parfois aussi concerne internet dans ce
domaine la faire en sorte que plus rien
ne bouge si vous me permettez cette
expression peut poser un problème à ceux
qui recherchent précisément ce type de
discours et de propagande
donc il faut pas créer non plus un
obstacle à la découverte j'en ai pas
plus d'un certain nombre d'éléments mais
il faut sans doute y travailler parce
que toute façon il ya une adaptation de
ce que nous vous proposons avec la garde
des sceaux c'est que nous puissions et
travailler sereinement pour voir quelles
sont les possibilités juridiques et
efficace puisque de nos un de vos
collègues évoqué la notion d'efficacité
pour que demain éventuellement nous
puissions avancer en l'occurrence comme
l'a dit la garde des sceaux ce soir sur
ce sujet là cela nous paraît difficile
merci monsieur le ministre alors nous
allons voter sur cet amendement 6
rectifier que ceux qui souhaitent
l'adopter veuille bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veuille
bien le gars là bas il n'est pas adopté
article additionnel après l'article 2
l'amendement 14e rectifier et présentée
par monsieur merci à monsieur ministre
si beaucoup monsieur prieur je crois
avoir déjà défendu cet amendement
longuement tout à l'heure et pas longer
le débat mais je demande au sénat de
voter
merci chers collègues pardon monsieur le
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission
oui monsieur le président c'est un avis
défavorable par cohérence avec la
position que nous avons pris sur les
amendements numéro 3 et numéro 13 si le
rapporteur est favorable défavorable a
pas de demande d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter venir
lever la main merci que ceux qui sont
opposés veuille bien levé la main il
n'est pas adopté article additionnel
après l'article 2 l'amendement 8e
rectifié be s'est présentée par monsieur
y est il est défendu
il est défendu monsieur rapporteur
l'avis de la commission le président
même avis défavorable similitudes avec
le débat que nous venons d'avoir type
monsieur ministre même avis défavorable
merci chers collègues même vote même
vote article additionnel après l'article
2 nous avons deux amendements et un
sous-amendement qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune tout d'abord
l'amendement 15 rectifier et présentée
par monsieur mercier alors nous
considérons qu'il est tombé
nous passons au cat rectifié bis
monsieur y est vous avez la parole comme
manifestement on ne voulait pas d'un
délit spécifique à au moins dans la
halle doit de 81 la loi de 1881 il faut
mieux prévoir quand même des des
prescriptions qui soit raisonnable parce
que c'est toujours compliqué mais le
délai de trois mois est extrêmement
brefs et use avec la procédure la loi de
80 elle a peut-être des vertus mais là
aussi des graves défauts de ce point de
vue quand il s'agit de choses graves et
c'est pourquoi je
vous est proposé de porter à un an le
délai de prescription
merci chers collègues nous avons un
sous-amendement 26 il est présenté par
monsieur le rapporteur de la commission
des lois
oui merci monsieur le président par
rapport à ce que vient d'exposer de
notre collègue jean jacky est
effectivement dans la loi de 1881 nous
avons un délai de prescription de trois
mois qu'on peut considérer comme trop
court par rapport aux problèmes qu'ils
posent et l'allongement un an paraît une
excellente chose
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas quelque chose
qui serait une création dans le cadre de
la loi de 1881
puisque c'est déjà prévu pour les
infractions les plus graves comme la
provocation à la discrimination à la
haine à la violence à l'égard d'une
personne à raison de son origine ou de
sa religion
il paraît donc logique au regard de la
gravité des faits incriminés et de
l'efficacité de la répression de prévoir
ces arrangements
nous avons proposé un amendement qui est
un article additionnel après l'article 2
qui vise à autoriser le placement en
détention provisoire en cas de
provocation ou d' apologie d'actes de
terrorisme car il faut souligner que
cette possibilité existe déjà notamment
pour les provocations aux atteintes
volontaires à la vie ou à l'intégrité de
la personne
il pouvait apparaître paradoxal dans ces
conditions que la provocation aux actes
de terrorisme ne puisse donner lieu
explicitement un placement en détention
provisoire
merci monsieur rapporteur sur donc la
banque at rectifié bis là
bien sûr l'avis du gouvernement madame
la garde des sceaux monsieur le
président donc il y à l'amendement et
sous-amendement et je présume que vous
mettrez aux votes auront donc je vais
m'exprimer d'abord sur le
sous-amendement donc pour dire que le
gouvernement émet un avis défavorable
vous aviez raison tout à l'heure
monsieur le ministre de dire que voilà
ce sera un aménagement en termes de
cohérence dans ce cas là nous aurions dû
effectivement adoptés votre amendement
tout à l'heure donc le gouvernement émet
un avis défavorable parce qu'il n'est
pas souhaitable que dans la loi de 1881
soit introduit la disposition ses
dispositions concernant la détention
provisoire nous considérons que la
possibilité de garde à vue permet la
poursuite des investigations et des
interrogations nécessaire par contre
pour ce qui concerne l'amendement et la
prorogation du délai de prescription à
la fois pour des raisons de gravité des
actes l'acte d'apologie et de
provocation aux actes terroristes et par
alignement
compte tenu du fait que il y à déjà ces
dérogations à l'intérieur de la loi de
1881 pour des incriminations évoqué
d'ailleurs à l'instant par le rapporteur
à savoir notamment l'incitation à la
haine au titre de la race ou de la
religion etc
la race j'y mets des guillemets vous
imaginez bien cela visait d'ailleurs
essentiellement des actes de d'apologie
et d'incitation à la haine antisémite
donc pour des raisons de gravité et de
cohérence dans l'alignement le
gouvernement est favorable à la
prorogation du délai actuel de trois
mois à un an
en étant je répète défavorable sous
amendement pour la détention provisoire
merci mr et mme le garde des sceaux
juste pour vous être agréable
pire monsieur rapporteur merci monsieur
le président ce mouvement une prévision
une précision dans la loi du 29 juillet
1881 il ya un article 50 2 qui indique
si la personne mise en examen est
domicilié en france ne pourra être
préventivement arrêtés sauf dans les cas
prévus aux articles 23 24 25 27 36 et 37
ci dessus c'est à dire que la détention
provisoire est donc possible et il
suffit d'aller d'ailleurs voir les
articles 23 24 pour voir les délits
auquel peut s'appliquer cette
disposition de l'article 52 m merci
monsieur le rapporteur
alors nous allons donc voter sur le 26
rectifié y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote il n'y en a pas
que ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter
veuille bien levé la main merci que ceux
qui sont contre veut bien levé la main
il est donc adoptée nous votons sur
leucate rectifié bis pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter va bien levé la main
dix neuf
je rappelle que le gouvernement la
commission sont favorables merci que
ceux qui que ceux qui souhaitent voter
contre veuille bien levé la main merci
il est donc adopté nous en arrivons à
l'article 3 deux amendements font
l'objet d'une discussion commune 1
l'amendement 23 rectifier et présentée
par monsieur ciani oui monsieur le
président madame et monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
cet amendement pour but de préciser les
précisions qui ont déjà été apportés par
la commission des lois au fonctionnement
de la commission qui a pour but de 10 y
aune et les personnes avant de procéder
à leur expulsion
la commission a excellemment déjà
précisé que le délai d'un mois devait
figurer dans la loi et pas uniquement
dans le règlement et puis également
envisagé que en cas de motif légitime
uniquement en cas de motif légitime et
bien on puisse accorder un nouveau délai
d'un mois pour que la commission puisse
rendre son avis nous vous proposons dans
cet amendement
mais nous attendons également aussi les
éclaircissements du gouvernement sur cet
amendement
d'apporter quelques modifications la
première c'est de préciser que au fond
les dispositions dont il s'agit ne
pourront s'appliquer que lorsqu'il
s'agit d'une procédure d'expulsion et
non pas sur la totalité des dispositions
du code concernant les laits de ces
états nous concernant les étrangers et
la deuxième précision c'est une pression
plus fort mal mais qui consiste à au
lieu de dire que la vie sera réputée
rendu en cas de non réponse de la
commission de préciser que les
formalités de consultation de la
commission seront réputés remplies nous
sommes que c'est une formulation plus
adéquat
merci chers collègues l'amendement 21
rectifiée présentée par la manne bassar
et nous demandons la rédaction de
l'article de l'article auch est fatigué
bon nous demandons la rédaction de la
partie 1 alinéa 2 de l'article 3 de la
manière suivante je cite la commission
aimé son avis dans un délai de deux mois
à compter de la convocation de
l'étranger de même nous le demandons
également la rédaction de la partie 2
alinéa 4 de la première phrase
la commission émet sur